Film Courage: Once you establish
yourself as a working television
director, do you interview for your next job?
Pete Chatmon, Director/Podcaster/Author: Oh yeah,
you do a lot of it. It's a lot of general meetings
before you ever get hired which is basically will
I get along with you? Are you crazy? meeting. You
do a lot of generals so a lot of so more and more
people can say oh really yeah a competent person
it's a nice enough person you get what we're doing
over here at our company maybe and somewhere along
the line someone's going to say okay we're going
to hire you Kenya Barris did for me in 2017. Then
you begin to build your resume hopefully you get
invited back to a show because that's kind of so
if the general meeting went well and people were
okay talented not crazy you get what we're doing
over here getting invited back is the affirmation
of that oh they must not have been crazy they must
have really done a nice job and they must
have really understood what the show wanted
the kind of industry not wisdom but saying or
whatever thought is that when you see someone with
a bunch of one episode at a bunch of different
places it's well why aren't you ever going back I
and so you get invited back then you do more and
more shows the beauty of of today that might mask
the invited back is that a lot of shows are doing
block episodes where you I did two at one time so
it might look you got invited back but once you do
enough work the work itself begins to be what vets
you so someone may say oh we're thinking about or
even for the shows that I'm unaware where we are
looking for directors you'll say oh they've done
XYZ and you can just look and tell that they've
have the skill set to do your show then you'll
probably call around and see if there are people
that you think people that know that person
that can give you a little bit more insight
into them so that's where the reputation and
and and that community is really important and
then after that you always have some kind
of Zoom which is maybe less of a meeting
it might they'll get to know you and you'll
probably speak really specifically to the
show so it's not a general it's about this
show and at that point I feel you're probably
it's probably your job to lose so I guess
the long answer to your question is at this
point I'll either get an offer or I'll get an
outright offer they want you to do these this
black episodes because they've done enough
vetting that they feel they don't need to
speak directly to me or they already know me
or they want to have a meeting on zoom and
if it's at that point they're probably highly
considering me for the job and that's the final
step what are a few do's and don'ts for a
general maybe don't don't speak too much
we might say the wrong thing or I think the
I think meetings are you got to find a way
to still be yourself in an unnatural
environment because it's it's kind
of speed dating what I mean and so I
feel the dues are to be very clear on
have a very clear and concise way to deliver
your your backstory and who you are your bio
your origin story to be very clear on why you
want to do the show hopefully who you are and
what you've done connects to the show so then
it becomes to make almost perfect sense why
you should be directing it don't come in there
and be unaware of the person you're talking to
there are so many opportunities to find a
connective thread that Google will help you
with whether it's oh you went to NYU or oh you're
from New Jersey or you worked with the person I
know on so-and-so project and they say hi any
little thing that that's not going to get you
the job but it it begins to warm things up
a little bit and I think be be clear about
what you offer to the show and ask questions
I think to come in and not have any questions
Belize a person who's not very curious because
with with those questions you gain information
not that I'm the I'm the model for it but I'm
thinking like you asked me a question about
this person versus that person and I'm well what
is that person's goal because that that's going to
help me kind of answer the question and sometimes
in a meeting asking questions helps you figure out
what you might not want to say and just absolute
don'ts well yeah it's the don't come in there
unprepared whether that's in understanding
the person in front of you and understanding
it their bio or some portion of it that you
can because sometimes I've come across a few
people where it's you scrub yourself from the
internet somehow and I don't know how you do
that but I don't know anything about you so
their personal bio their their bio here at
this job what do they have the power to do I are
they the person who hires are they the person who
weeds out and then this is the meeting that gets
you to the next person who may actually be able
to hire what projects are they proud of is has
anything been greenlit recently or did a show
just premiere last week and watch that show and
be able to talk about it because that shows that
you're invested in what they do as well because
at the end of the day I think the way I try and
view working professionally in a world full
of collaborative creative people is I want as
many people to make their projects as possible
I'm here to be a support for that whether it's
maybe it's feedback or maybe it's directing an
episode or maybe it's a go get them champ but
providing that type of energy I
think is something that folks are
happy to have around them and
lastly how early is too early
for what for to show up at one of these meetings
oh how early it's too early to arrive I mean
make sure you're there on time I get I try and
get there 30 minutes early but then you won't
see me in the lobby until five minutes
before what I mean okay maybe maybe 10.
10 is a good amount of time because I want to
you do want to give yourself time to get in
sit down reap run through whatever you might
have prepared again sometime it might be
going into the bathroom and stretching out a
little bit or whatever whatever you need to do
but don't don't walk in there at 128 for 1 30
Because unless you've got some abilities that I
don't have to smoothly transition to meeting
mode you don't go in expecting to be hired
instead you go in to make it impossible for
them not to hire you how is that different so
the way I view it is and this is I think I think a
big takeaway from the book is that I'm I'm big on
viewing things through the prism that I can
control I and and viewing things in a way that
really prevents getting beaten down by the
realities of of what we do in a world where
you're selected and or not selected for reasons
known and unknown fickle and and arbitrary and
sometimes spot on and so my thought was when I was
trying to get jobs and and I still carry it with
me is that I understand that there are people who
will be easier to hire for a particular job and
that happens now but my job is to come into this
meeting and make it the most challenging decision
for them to not hire me so what does that mean I'm
going to come in and tell my bio origin story and
it's going to be concise it's going to be whatever
funny it's going to I'm going to give you the best
me that's honest but designed to connect with
what we're talking about here is a project as
possible I'm going to show you that I've done
my research I'm going to speak about the show
because I've watched enough to develop a point of
view that's informed I'm going to be interested
in asking questions about it I'm going to
let outright how much I want to do this show
all the things that make it where you're
looking at the grid of people up for it
you may have somebody that's done more work
than I have in this particular genre or just
at all but maybe they weren't as exciting a
meeting maybe they didn't outright tell you
they want the job maybe they didn't get into
a really deep dive conversation into the show
and I understand why you would still hire
them over me if for all the reasons that
make hiring what hiring is but I want that to be
a tough decision and my thought was if I if I can
build a Rolodex a database a spreadsheet full of
meetings where that was the end result at some
point somebody's going to be all I this is the
I one for him I see so yeah so then it's kind
of nebulous that's I'm going there to get hired
versus I'm going to make sure that they can't
not hire me because that seems it checks more
boxes I feel they're that's clear to me and
it's the actor's audition I the actors audition
is you can't you can't audition to get the job
that if you do that you're going to be depressed
because how many jobs are you going to get you
have no control over that but what you can do and
this is from me on the other side of the table
watching auditions what you the auditions that
land are I can tell that you had a perspective
you made a choice you prepared and you executed
on that choice and whatever those three things
were you gave you provided a tape that was your
best presentation of those things and then ain't
nothing else you can do about it what I mean
we can debate oh we might say oh well she's the
person that we've already cast for her sister she
doesn't look anything her and it's a big stretch
because that's important and so no we don't hire
that person and they may have been the best person
but there's another reason why they might not have
gotten a job and so directors are auditioning in
in a similar in in somewhat of a similar way and
just taking the reins and making sure you show
them what you can do show them who you are and
let them decide but make it hard and how do you
say I would love to take on this opportunity or is
that what you say that's what I would say outright
so so maybe two other people might think that but
that's too passive and they just go okay great so
yeah just please keep me in mind you basically let
it be known let it be known I want this because
there's and and my estimation is that on on this
fictitious sheet of paper of names that are that
are up for something maybe one or two of them
are doing it because their agent said they should
all I and maybe it's attractive to the people
behind the show because oh it's so-and-so
or maybe they used to be so-and-so cool but I'm
going to come in and I'm going to there will be no
doubt and in a world of meetings where folks are
having 40 meetings a week these things begin to
stand out and lastly do you send
a follow-up email or even a card
I well it depends sometimes I have there are a
lot of relationships where I don't have any of
these folks information because the reps at the
meeting and then you go and that's kind of how the
reps remain where they remain as the conduit
and then sometimes I'll have folks who will
yeah folks who will be oh here's my
card and then that kind of lets you know
hey the meeting went well but
also they have a maybe different
kind of relationship they're trying to build.